usually rap to me is the backbone of
hip-hop but the music that I make is
different there's no one in my lane
that's doing what I'm doing
I'm bar dealing the king and I make
trailer I rap
[Music]
trail ride is basically our culture is
basically what we love to do it's really
a lifestyle if you might hear the
witnesses and you want to understand
back in the days of people before my
grandfather used to saddle up a mule a
donkey backpacking through the woods and
they made a trail well we don't have
woods no more
so we ride up and down the streets two
by two in a line representing the trail
riding riding trucks playing mullet ride
horses get on the party wagon it'd
probably be for hours trying to be five
our numbers very into the thousands we
have our own community we have our own
little world no you got your blues and
you got to zydeco it's a Cajun style of
music that comes from Louisiana that's
played by a band or accordion a rubber
board lead guitar some people use
keyboards growing up as a young kid I
was always on a horse trail riding so
what I did was I interpret all that into
my music when I started rapping there
was really no rap allowed on trail ride
I came in and I wanted to change that
trying to break the bear for young
people to enjoy trail right because I
was a youngster out there on the trail
ride but you had a hobby such as trail
riding it'll pull you away from the
street I know because it's a lot of
people that trail right there used to
sell drugs that you still you know do a
lot of stuff that wasn't right now
they've come to trail riding and they
love my music
my fear
right
[Music]
[Applause]
it means that I make it just for the
culture I represent us for the trail
riders just for the zydeco artists just
for everything that we do country I
really feel like I had something to do
with the changing of the face of Trevor
[Music]